The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
TIM RAY: I guess
first of all I wanted
to entertain any questions you
might've had about the concert.
I know Mark is having you
write up some reports.
Actually I got an advanced
copy of one person's report
that had some really
interesting comments.
One of the comments
that this person wrote
was about hearing--
trying to listen
for the difference between
the improvised sections
and the written sections.
What was your feeling on that?
Did you feel like you had
a pretty good sense of when
we were improvising and when
we were playing written music?
Was it a little hard to
tell sometimes, right?
I actually tell-- we hear
that comment a lot, actually.
Including from symphony players.
It might have been hard for you
to tell, don't think that means
anything negative.
Like I say, a lot of musicians
come up to us afterwards
and they go, I don't know
what you guys were doing,
or how you were
blending the composition
and the improvisation.
And that's, to me, is sort
of an affirmation of one
of my goals for this group,
is to blend composition
and improvisation in
kind of a seamless way.
I mean, it's obviously
not seamless,
but to make that-- make
those lines blurry.
And I think a lot of
composers of modern music--
I know Mark Harvey's
compositions do somewhat
the same thing, as well
as of course Greg's.
And a lot of people
I know sometimes
look for that kind of blurry
line between composition
improvisation.
Because it's really all
the same thing, right?
It's just composition,
you write it down.
Improvisation is
spontaneous, but still it's
all kind of the same thing.
The piece that you transcribed
from an improvisation,
did you play that--
were you playing it
exactly how it
sounded originally?
Or did you kind
of reinterpret it?
Because it sounded
like a real piece.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, that's--
GREG HOPKINS: (LAUGHING)
What do you mean by that?
TIM RAY: Yeah, right.
GREG HOPKINS: I
know what you mean.
I know exactly what you mean.
TIM RAY: Sounded like real
music, not improvisation.
No, I'm teasing.
No, that's a good question.
That's another one
people ask a lot.
Yeah, that was, again,
that was sort of Eugene's.
That was something
that he had improvised
with a different piano player
years ago in this cathedral.
Now he talked about it
a little bit, I know.
GREG HOPKINS: Oh, you're talking
about the piano-cello piece.
TIM RAY: Yeah, the
piano-cello piece, right.
And as he said,
they wrote it out.
I mean, they wrote it out.
Eugene kind of just
memorized his cello part.
And his part was
pretty much as played,
as improvised back however
many years ago that was.
And then the piano part, they
wrote it out and of course,
being a jazz player
I changed it.
So I mean I basically
followed the intent of it,
you know, and I played
something specific to what
was played back then, as
according to the music.
But then I did some other--
I changed it up a little bit.
Made it a little
bit more-- gave it
a little bit of a personal
thing, a personal touch.
But yeah, that's
one of the things.
I know you weren't
here last week
when we were doing the thing
with diatonic improvisation,
but basically that's
what that was.
It was a whole thing
about just improvising
in the key of D major.
And Eugene and this
guy, Paul Halley,
was the pianist, basically
did an amazing job of kind
of creating this thing.
And as you said, it
sounded like real music.
It sounded like something
that could have been composed.
It had sections and
melody in the cello,
melody in the piano,
all kinds of variations
and accompaniments.
And like I said,
that was just one
of those things that kind
of worked out really well
improvisationally and
happened to be recorded.
And so that that's why
it keeps getting played.
But yeah, so I don't know if
that answered your question,
but that's kind of
the genesis of that.
So, cool.
And then Greg and I--
GREG HOPKINS: He probably played
the piece though, many times,
right?
TIM RAY: Yeah, yeah.
Eugene's played that
piece many times.
GREG HOPKINS: So it's not
improvisation of the moment,
it's a creation that he
recreates many times over
and over and over.
So they kind of played
it similar each time.
TIM RAY: Right, yeah.
You know, and
sometimes it's funny
because we, Greg and I and Mark,
are kind of jazz-- you know,
what we might call
hardcore jazz guys.
Who sort of believe
in the sanctity
of spontaneous improvisation.
But actually, if you look back
not that long ago in history
that happened a lot.
Duke Ellington spans
a perfect example.
Cootie Williams would
take a trumpet solo
and Duke would say, I like
that, do that solo again.
The next thing you know,
that Cootie Williams solo
becomes part of the book.
What started off as an
improvisation, or at least
largely as an improvisation,
became part of the music.
So there's a little bit of
history even in the jazz
world--
GREG HOPKINS: Well,
a lot of jazz music
starts out as improvisation
and becomes concrete.
Like some of Charlie
Parker's tunes.
And he would play them
the same each time.
OK, this is the melody.
And they're nothing but,
really, improvisations
that become part of history.
TIM RAY: Indeed.
And then, the duet
that Greg and I
did, I made a little comment
at the beginning about I
didn't know what
was going to happen.
And it's kind of
true, I don't really
know what's going to happen.
That's one of those
moments, which
I like to do in our program, and
Greg and I have done this a lot
over the course of our--
GREG HOPKINS: We never decide
what tune we're going to play.
TIM RAY: Yeah, well
we don't decide it.
I'm happy to have Greg start.
And I don't know, did you--
when you started did you know--
GREG HOPKINS: I had no idea.
TIM RAY: I had a
feeling you were--
GREG HOPKINS: I was
searching around,
I was kind of doing a
little prelude stuff.
Saying, now what do I feel
like I want to play here?
Well, we just played something
in sharp key so I said,
we're going to go into flats.
Because I wanted to
have a different taste.
And A-flat came out, OK, well
let's-- I know this tune.
And, hey let's play
rhythm changes in A-flat,
and then we went into
the Thelonious Monk
tune "Little Rootie Tootie".
Which we-- I know that
Tim knows and I know.
So basically after a
little fooling around,
OK, let's do that, no problem.
But we had fun
with Monk's riffs,
so then we really
played the composition.
And as a composer, I think
that's-- I really appreciate
that, when an improviser or a
soloist plays the composition.
Because that's a strong way
to approach a improvisation--
playing the musical composition
instead of just playing
your horn, your instrument.
And playing a bunch of licks
and making the changes is fine,
but what does it all mean
related to Mr. Monk's music?
Because I put myself not
as so much a soloist,
it's not about me
as much as it's
about how can I interpret
his composition.
So I'm more like the conduit
instead of the focal point.
So we had a lot of
fun with his riffs.
TIM RAY: Yeah, we did.
And that gets a little bit back
to what we were talking about
with the assignment,
which is this tune
of Greg's, [? "Karagassian". ?]
GREG HOPKINS: Oh,
you have that one?
TIM RAY: Yeah, you guys
all brought it, right?
All right, so we're going to
start playing in just a second.
But the idea, being to--
obviously, get the foundation.
In other words,
learn the melody,
get comfortable with the minor
blues progression-- which
is what the improvisation
is based on-- if you're not
already comfortable
with that, and then use
some of the motifs in the melody
to inform your improvisation.
Use to improvise in the motivic
fashion, as much as you can.
I mean, you don't--
obviously, no one-- well,
I shouldn't say no one.
It would be rare to hear
an improvisation created
completely out of motivic
stuff, although I'm
sure it's been done.
GREG HOPKINS: Sure it is.
TIM RAY: Some of my favorite
improvisers do that.
I mean they don't--
GREG HOPKINS: I'm always
playing the melody up here.
Even when I play a standard
tune, I'm on the melody.
So then you're never at
a loss for what to do.
I don't really have
to think of something.
It's here.
Do something with that.
TIM RAY: Yeah, that's true.
GREG HOPKINS: But then
what do you do with it?
You have to know your
compositional techniques.
Repetition, sequence,
transposition, elongation,
augmentation, diminution,
transformation, embellishment,
all that stuff.
TIM RAY: Yeah, absolutely.
GREG HOPKINS: And
then sometimes we
play stuff, little
cannons back and forth.
Question and answer,
question and answer.
TIM RAY: Yeah, cool.
So, should we jump
into this piece?
What do we think?
Yeah, we've got plenty of time.
OK, so [? "Karagassian". ?] I
know I suggested maybe we have
you guys do some-- you
know, pair up to do some
improvisations.
But maybe just for
rehearsal sake,
why don't we all
play the melody.
And we'll see if we're
on the same page.
GREG HOPKINS: So, as you know
this is written for my cat.
My late cat [? Karagassian. ?]
I wrote the piece probably
in 15 minutes.
It just came out.
Because the cat
had so much spirit.
And it's all here.
You know cats,
they're very playful.
So this melody's very playful.
It's meant to be had
a lot of fun with.
TIM RAY: Yes, indeed.
So yeah, so let's
all play the melody.
If you guys on guitar
want to do some chord
changes in the
three-four measure
you can, or you can just
stay with the melody
if you want to do that.
Let's just do that and
see where we're at.
And then we'll get
into some improv.
Do you want to
count it off, Greg?
GREG HOPKINS: One,
two, a one, two, three.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIM RAY: That's a hard one.
All right.
Not bad.
GREG HOPKINS: Not bad at all.
But the inflection
is pretty good.
Yeah, it's really
soft and distant.
And then in the third measure
we can clobber that note.
Actually, play a different
note than E-flat.
That's like a crash.
One more time.
A one, two, a one, two.
Yeah, but softer.
Much softer.
Just touch it.
One, two, a one, two.
That's it.
One, two.
Loud.
Two, three,four.
One, two.
So I always put a doit on that.
You know what a doit is?
Where you fall up?
It's a fall up instead
of a fall down.
TIM RAY: Yeah, it's always
hard on a piano, right?
I usually just
[INAUDIBLE] short little--
GREG HOPKINS:
That's an old term ,
nobody talks about
that stuff anymore.
D-O-I-T it's called doit.
Doy-eet.
TIM RAY: Where are we?
GREG HOPKINS: Bar nine.
Third line.
Two, a one, two, three.
Two, three.
Three, four.
Good.
A two, a one, two.
Quiet.
Two, three.
Yeah, nice.
So the fermata would
just be for the ending.
And then we would go
to that three four bar
and then go right back to the
beginning and start the blues.
TIM RAY: The blues is
in four four by the way,
and I know the chart's
not clear about that.
But, yeah four four blues.
For the improv.
GREG HOPKINS: Yeah.
So the whole ending
part is supposed
to create this tension,
a little angst.
With the rhythm, four against
three, and then the four
goes faster than you think.
And then when we start
to play the blues form,
it relaxes back
to regular tempo.
So the cat's kind of clawing
its way up the curtain.
But we don't play-- we
don't improvise on that,
but you could certainly
include the motifs
in your improvisations.
TIM RAY: Cool.
GREG HOPKINS: Should we
do it with some solos?
TIM RAY: Yeah, let's
do it with some solos.
Yeah.
GREG HOPKINS: Now, we perform
it as a totally conversational
piece.
There's no accompaniment.
Everybody's just soloing
at the same time, which
is an interesting
style which I like.
I tend to play a lot less when
I'm playing conversationally.
Because you want the
person to talk back to you.
You can't be like
some professors who
just talk and talk
and talk and talk
and you can't say anything.
OK.
Just take notes.
TIM RAY: Cool.
But you want to-- maybe
we'll start with-- well,
let's play the melody again.
And then, and then maybe we'll
do a little bit of soloing.
I'll maybe keep the form--
GREG HOPKINS: It's going to
be tough with this many people
to play conversationally.
TIM RAY: Yeah, well maybe
by the end we'll get there.
We won't start there, though.
But I would like to hear
some people kind of pair off.
But you want-- maybe we should
do, like, individually first.
GREG HOPKINS: Yeah, I think so.
Let's do a chorus each.
TIM RAY: Cool, all right.
GREG HOPKINS: And will you comp?
TIM RAY: Yeah,
I'll do some comp.
GREG HOPKINS: Yeah, do
some typical comping.
Base notes, you play the melody.
I mean, all you need
really is base and melody.
Two parts to have counterpoint.
Any two lines could
be counterpointal.
Then there's conversational.
Much more fun than
playing alone.
GUEST SPEAKER: And we've
all-- everybody's assignment
was to prepare, right?
Some thoughts about how
you would treat the motif.
So why don't we start there?
Then we see how that expands.
TIM RAY: Cool.
GREG HOPKINS: So, do the melody
once and then we'll start.
So just go around,
you want to go first?
We'll go around.
We can start there.
A one, two.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIM RAY: Yeah, all right.
Cool.
Let's stop there.
Nice, all right.
Great, it's great to
hear all of you play.
Excellent, thank you.
GREG HOPKINS: So we
all played one chorus.
TIM RAY: Yeah, so we
all did one chorus.
While I heard a lot
of really nice ideas,
I didn't hear a whole
lot of use of the motifs.
Let's look at those real quick.
GREG HOPKINS: I heard
the first motif a lot.
TIM RAY: Did you?
OK.
GREG HOPKINS: Yeah,
some of you played
that opening, which
I did five times.
But I transposed it each time.
So it kind of created a
little line cliche, as we say.
TIM RAY: Indeed.
Indeed.
Right.
So that first one, I think
we looked at these just
briefly last time.
Yeah, the first one
is a good one to grab.
The repeated note,
that's a nice one.
GREG HOPKINS: Number
two, number two.
That's funky.
TIM RAY: That's
pretty funky, yeah.
GREG HOPKINS: You
could go [PLAYS MUSIC].
You could go [PLAYS MUSIC].
Just play it, you
could do-- yeah,
we could do several
choruses just on that.
TIM RAY: Just on that, I know.
And we probably have.
GREG HOPKINS: By
changing notes, I'm
using the rhythmic
contours of motif.
So, the da da da da, I could
do anything I want there.
[PLAYS MUSIC]
Yeah.
You could work your way through
creating interesting melodies
by changing the notes.
TIM RAY: Yeah, absolutely.
Do you want to do a little
motivic exercise, maybe?
We'll go-- we'll
do the same thing.
We'll go around the--
GREG HOPKINS: Let's
just play that motif.
Da da da da.
TIM RAY: Yeah.
GREG HOPKINS: So you
can play four notes.
One two three four.
You can play any
intervals, though.
TIM RAY: Cool.
GREG HOPKINS: Not yet.
This is my warm up,
Mark, for the day.
[LAUGHTER]
GUEST SPEAKER: Pretty good.
GREG HOPKINS: It's a
good tune to warm up on.
TIM RAY: It is.
So, you want to do
everybody four measures?
GREG HOPKINS: Let's do--
TIM RAY: [INAUDIBLE]
Sure.
Four bars each.
TIM RAY: What do you think?
OK.
Just doing that motif.
Just the repeated note motif.
All right.
Why don't you start.
GREG HOPKINS: A two, a one, two.
Good Nice idea.
Yeah.
Do another one.
You go.
One.
AUDIENCE: From this [INAUDIBLE]?
GREG HOPKINS: Yeah.
Flute.
TIM RAY: You ready?
Yeah, nice.
GREG HOPKINS: Next solo.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
So we're setting parameters now.
You have to use that material
and create with that.
It's like, I mean we're
sculptors, Let's face it,
we're just shaping stuff
out of these materials.
So sometimes it's really
good to limit yourself.
That's what an etude
is, an etude is always
like one idea for
the whole page.
And the composer of
the etude does it
in all the different
keys so you'll learn it.
So it's really good to set the
parameters like that I think.
TIM RAY: Yeah, oh
I think so too.
I think it's a great
way to-- you know,
there's all kinds of parameters.
You can obviously-- we're
doing the little motivic thing
with the four
notes, but you can,
obviously-- there's any
number of other motifs
you could do that with.
You can do set
parameters, as far
as the range of
your instruments,
or dynamics, or
rhythmic density,
you know, do a solo
with all quarter notes.
Right?
Or do a solo with all
quarter note triplets, right?
Something like that,
that's another great way
to kind of expand your range.
In other words,
expand your range
of what you're doing
with improvisation.
Let's do another one of those.
Let's see, what's another
good motif to grab?
GREG HOPKINS: Bar
nine is pretty good.
That might be a little hard.
Well, the opening motif is good.
TIM RAY: Cool.
Cool.
Yeah, let's do the same thing.
Four measures again?
GREG HOPKINS: Four measures.
We'll do the opening motif.
Two, a one, two, three.
Nice.
Go ahead.
Change direction.
Nice.
TIM RAY: Yeah.
GREG HOPKINS: OK.
So, I mean, how would you
practice something like that?
Well, let's play that motif.
Just those three notes.
OK, let's go up in half steps.
So I'm going to sequence it, I'm
going to play it in every key.
OK, and then we
go (PLAYS MUSIC).
Yeah.
So the first one, D
G, D G, D G D. Now,
what am I-- I'm
hearing in my head,
I'm hearing five one five.
So I'm hearing it in the key.
Up a half.
So an A-flat now.
Let's do it in A. A.
Next key.
Yeah, good.
OK?
So then we could (PLAYS MUSIC).
You can put it in, and we could
do the same thing going down.
We could do the motif down.
I mean, that's what you
do when you practice.
You do really mundane--
maybe not mundane,
you do really small,
little things.
I mean, it might
take me 10 minutes
to really feel comfortable
with that, just those intervals
going up in sequences like that.
TIM RAY: Yeah, absolutely.
GREG HOPKINS: And then
you could sequence
things four different ways.
Let's sequence it
in whole steps.
Up a whole step, I'm going to
go up a whole step each time.
Too high?
Yeah.
So the person is going
to be in G then A then B
then C-sharp, then E-flat,
then F, and then G again.
Right?
TIM RAY: Yeah.
Absolutely.
GREG HOPKINS: Can we do that?
TIM RAY: Sure.
GREG HOPKINS: Let's just go up.
Skip the first note.
Now I'm going to sequence
just the first measure.
Right.
That's it.
There I go.
It's the whole thing, now
it's a whole different animal.
Now it sounds like a
progression, right?
TIM RAY: It does.
Yeah, absolutely.
GREG HOPKINS: So
that creates it.
And we can do it
in minor thirds.
OK?
Let's do that over a G pedal.
Yeah, that creates kind
of a bluesy feeling.
It's like a G diminished chord.
TIM RAY: Yeah, absolutely.
Right, yeah.
GREG HOPKINS: So now I'm
creating counterpoint just
with the motif.
Then we could do
it in major thirds.
That's an interesting one too--
TIM RAY: It is.
GREG HOPKINS: You think?
TIM RAY: Oh yeah.
Absolutely.
GREG HOPKINS: This is-- I
learned all this from him.
[LAUGHTER]
Let's do that over a D pedal.
TIM RAY: Sure.
GREG HOPKINS: One, two.
Then we could do cycle four.
So we did half steps,
whole steps, minor thirds,
major thirds, what's
the next interval?
Above a major third
is a perfect fourth.
So this is going-- there's
going to be 12 of them.
This is cycle five, right?
TIM RAY: Sure, yeah.
Yeah, right.
Or you can just--
GREG HOPKINS: Now we're
going to expand it.
We're going to
play a minor triad.
Instead of just one five, we're
going to play one three five.
Let's play up and
down a minor triad.
So we embellished the lick.
That's fine.
You can add notes
whenever you want.
Why'd you do that?
I wanted to.
G minor, so now we're
going to do cycles,
so we're going to go a forth
up to C minor, fourth up to F
minor, B-flat minor, E-flat
minor, A-flat minor, D-flat
minor, G-flat minor, B minor,
E minor, A minor, D minor,
back to G. Slowly.
Ready, go.
So now I'm going to
take that same idea
and do it in whole steps.
And so on.
It's all just grunt work.
But that's what Coltrane did.
He used to practice in his
apartment eight hours a day.
Eight hours a day just on
these-- what he was playing.
He made up his own etudes.
Yeah, he did.
Which is what all the good--
all the great players do.
TIM RAY: Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, certainly--
GREG HOPKINS: This is the model.
This is the model.
This has dozens of ideas.
TIM RAY: Yeah, and
certainly that's
the idea of any kind of
work on improvisation.
You know, when you're sitting
alone at home thinking,
you know, because
everyone always says,
well I don't know how to
practice improvisation.
GREG HOPKINS: Yeah,
what should I do?
Oh, I'm going to play
my scales every day.
OK, that's fine.
TIM RAY: Because
it's spontaneous.
GREG HOPKINS: You got make
goals, a set of goals.
And we can tell you what goals,
what projects to work on.
TIM RAY: But yeah.
But a lot of it's just about
coming up with stuff like this.
Obviously, as Greg said,
we can tell you stuff
or you could go
buy books that have
patterns and stuff like that.
And that's all great,
but sometimes it's
just about what
we're doing, which
is like, OK, let's try that.
Now let's try it up a fourth.
And let's find this
little two bar thing.
I mean, if you want
to get more difficult
you can find something
even in a tune like this.
Something that's a
little more difficult
and try that in all 12 keys.
GREG HOPKINS: Let's
do bar 17, you know.
[LAUGHTER]
TIM RAY: Yeah, right.
No, I'm not going to try it.
GREG HOPKINS:
That's a-- basically
it's this a B-flat lick.
Yeah, that was my
idea, I want to go
from B-flat to B-flat with some
kind of maybe 12 tone idea,
I don't know what it is.
TIM RAY: Yeah, so
that's, as Greg says,
a lot of just sitting alone
at home work that's, I think,
that's really helpful.
All the great players did it.
They all spent 10,000 hours.
Is that the current idea?
GREG HOPKINS: I
do the same thing.
I do the same thing
with my scales.
How do you practice your scales?
Well, you do them in intervals.
I mean, what is a melody?
Let's define melody.
This is a good place to do it.
Let's have a real technical
definition of melody.
Anybody, what is melody?
First thing that
comes into your head.
What's the melody?
AUDIENCE: Whatever
you'd sing after you're
done listening to it.
GREG HOPKINS: Yeah, whatever
you hear-- what did you say?
AUDIENCE: Whatever
you would sing
after you were done
listening to it.
GREG HOPKINS: Good, yeah,
whatever you'd sing.
You're a melody player, violin,
you're all melody players.
Yeah.
You guys, too.
What's melody to you?
AUDIENCE: It's
kind of the song--
GREG HOPKINS: It's
the song, very good.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GREG HOPKINS: Many
people say that.
It's the main idea.
It's the meaning.
Technically, is this music?
No, this is paper
with ink on it.
This is graph paper.
Pitch goes up and down,
time goes that way.
This is not music.
It's only music when you
realize it, when you play it.
So, the better you are
at creating intervals,
the better you'll be
at melody playing.
A melody is a
series of intervals
in some kind of rhythm.
So if I play-- that's the sixth.
So six down, fourth
up, third up,
minor sixth down, half step
up, half step, half step.
That's what a melody is,
it's a series of intervals,
that's all.
In some kind of time, right?
Every melody-- that's a
third, and then a fourth.
Another third, second
second, major seventh.
So, when we're playing
our scales, right?
That's all the
same scale, I just
played different intervals.
I'll play the scale
in seconds, I'll
play the scale in thirds,
fourths, fifths, sixths,
and sevenths.
Let's play G melodic minor.
No, G-natural minor.
Good, yeah, up and down.
One note in the top.
Go.
Now play it in thirds.
Now play it in fourths, slowly.
Now in fifths.
Nice.
Sixth is really pretty.
Sevenths is even more diverse,
a little obtuse, maybe?
Yeah.
Octaves.
Ninths.
I mean, you could
expand it even further.
TIM RAY: Sure.
GREG HOPKINS: You
do that, right?
TIM RAY: Yeah.
GREG HOPKINS: You've got
to learn your intervals.
TIM RAY: Of course.
Yeah, absolutely.
GREG HOPKINS: And also
inherent in the scale
is diatonic triads and
diatonic seventh chords.
Do you do that in class?
GUEST SPEAKER: We
haven't done that.
Have you done that with Tom?
GREG HOPKINS: Yeah,
play up all the triads
in the G minor scale.
TIM RAY: Yeah, well, right.
If you're doing natural minor.
GREG HOPKINS: Let's do that.
It's just building blocks.
This is the building blocks
of melody and harmony.
TIM RAY: Yeah, that's true.
GREG HOPKINS: And then
as you study each scale,
each scale is different.
Each scale has
characteristic notes
that make it function
different than other scales.
That's what makes
the scales different,
is the different notes.
And how the architecture
of the scale
works and draws things together.
So, I mean that's what we
study when we practice.
I'll practice
scales and I'll try
to really get the
meaning out of the scale.
This scale, natural
minor, is-- Yeah, I
mean there's certain things that
make that scale work, right?
TIM RAY: Sure, absolutely.
GREG HOPKINS: Flat sixth, right?
TIM RAY: Yeah, yeah.
Absolutely.
GREG HOPKINS: So if I'm
playing a natural minor,
I immediately know that the flat
sixth is a real strong note.
Let's just play a natural--
we'll play a natural minor just
for a minute.
TIM RAY: Sure.
GREG HOPKINS: G, so it'll
be like C minor, right?
Another chord?
TIM RAY: Right, yeah.
GREG HOPKINS: So one,
two, a one, two, three.
Yeah.
TIM RAY: Yeah, all right.
GREG HOPKINS: So
you're using D seven?
TIM RAY: Yeah, I used D seven.
GREG HOPKINS: Oh,
you used D seven, OK.
TIM RAY: Yeah, I threw that in.
Which is not technically part--
GUEST SPEAKER: We did
this with [INAUDIBLE],
and so you're already
talking [INAUDIBLE].
GREG HOPKINS: This
is aeolian mode.
It's called the aeolian mode.
Let's just play G minor C minor.
TIM RAY: Yeah.
GREG HOPKINS: One bar each.
One two three four--
I think modes is a great way
to start learning harmony.
TIM RAY: Absolutely, yeah.
GREG HOPKINS: Because
there's only one note,
really, that's really strong.
So here were playing G minor
for a bar and C minor for a bar.
G minor, C minor.
What's the note that
changes the most?
When you play the C minor
it's going to be the E-flat.
The E-flat.
So the G minor has
a D in it, right?
In then you go to C minor.
[SINGS NOTE]
So that's the
meaning of aeolian.
TIM RAY: Absolutely, yeah.
GREG HOPKINS: You could
play E-flat major,
would be a good
chord too, I think.
Let's play a bar each,
G minor and C minor.
Let's start over here, guitar.
One, a two, a one,
two, three, four.
Good.
Yeah.
Yeah, OK.
Got the idea?
Yeah, that's good.
I mean that's really
good for your ear.
Now I'm really working
on a small slice
of harmonic information
that I could put to use.
Now you played D seven before,
what scale would that be?
TIM RAY: Yeah, right?
So, D seven has got
what note in it--
GREG HOPKINS: What
note does D seven have?
TIM RAY: --that doesn't
belong in the aeolian--
GREG HOPKINS: That's different.
TIM RAY: Yeah, right.
You played it, Chris.
F-sharp, right?
GREG HOPKINS: F-sharp.
Yeah.
So that's kind of
like G-- now we've
got to learn G
harmonic minor scale.
Which has that very interesting
augmented second interval.
Gives it an exotic, Middle
Eastern or Detroit flavor.
Let's play harmonic minor.
One, two, three.
Let's play the triads in
harmonic minor-- slowly.
One, two-- Yeah.
The three chord's very
interesting, augmented chord.
And the four chord
is still minor.
So it's similar to aeolian
but it has the much preferred
leading tone, the F-sharp.
TIM RAY: Yes, indeed.
GREG HOPKINS: Just for fun, now
let's play G minor for a bar
and D seven flat nine for a bar.
What do you think?
TIM RAY: Yeah.
GREG HOPKINS: Flute first.
Nah, I'll start.
Two, a one, two, three--
Yeah, yeah, nice.
Yeah, and so on.
It's another small
slice of harmony
but it's different
than the first one.
So you practice that and you
practice it, and then it sinks
in your ear.
Because this is nothing
but ear training.
All this is just ear training
so you can pick your flavors.
OK, I want this flavor, I
want that color, that mood,
that sound.
Then there's melodic minor.
Yeah, because when
you play a minor key
you don't just
play one scale, we
mix four or five
minor scales together.
And if I play a
certain note, he'll
hear it and play the voicing
behind me, or whatever.
TIM RAY: Exactly.
That's where listening
comes into play.
Listening to the
person you're with.
GREG HOPKINS: When Wayne
Shorter was in the Army
he used to spend a
month on one scale.
He would practice the
key of D-flat for months.
He'd play every tune
he knew in D-flat.
He'd practice the scales,
he'd practice the chords,
he'd play rhythm changes,
blues, everything in one key.
And Coltrane did the same thing.
All the guys that practiced.
I have a tape of Clifford
Brown practicing the bridge
to "Cherokee" for an hour.
And you know he
did it every day.
Played with his mute.
TIM RAY: Cool.
So I also wanted
to get back to--
and this great
information, certainly-- I
wanted to get back the idea
of having you guys pair up
a little bit.
And maybe try it without me
doing the accompaniment, which
of course is about listening, as
I was saying just a second ago,
listening to who you're with.
Without the accompaniment
it becomes--
what becomes more important?
This is like as Greg
and I and Eugene
were doing with
the song, where we
were all kind of soloing
at the same time.
That's what I want to try to
get you guys to do a little bit.
And what aspect of
music becomes more
important in that situation.
Something we haven't really
talked about yet today.
GREG HOPKINS: So let's have
flute, sax, and guitar.
TIM RAY: What I was getting
at was rhythm, right?
Again, getting back to the
idea that we're all time
keepers, right.
I mean, when you hear
somebody like Greg who
is a great improviser, his
rhythmic ideas are very clear.
His rhythmic ideas
are very clear,
and if he does
something intentionally
that's a little less
clear, he follows it up
with something that's more clear
so that the people around him
know where the beats are, right?
So that's another thing that's
really important to work on
and I know we did a little
thing with rhythm with Eugene
last time.
AUDIENCE: So are we doing
an accompaniment solo type
thing or more like
a conversational?
TIM RAY: I think we should try
doing like a conversational--
GREG HOPKINS: Conversation.
So nobody's really
comping, you're
all playing your own ideas.
I'm leaving space for
other people's ideas.
TIM RAY: Right.
So what we'll do is
maybe have you guys play.
You're all improvising again,
leaving space, conversing.
I'll do a baseline for 12
bars and then I'll drop
and you guys keep going.
OK?
So this will be improv.
We're not going
to do the melody,
just starting right
with the improv.
Feel free to throw in
some motivic stuff, some
of the things Greg was talking
about in terms of the scales,
obviously G minor scale can
figure prominently in this.
OK, so here we go.
Right at the top of the improv.
One, a two, a one, two, three--
GREG HOPKINS: One more?
One more.
Not bad.
That was good.
TIM RAY: That was good.
Everybody feel where
the time was, right?
Felt pretty secure to me.
And then listening, really nice.
One of the motifs we
haven't touched on,
which is the quarter
note triplets, right?
Quarter note
triplets are tricky,
because that's against
the feeling of duple.
Against the feeling
of two and four,
which is-- any
song in four four,
most songs tend to
spend most of their time
either quarter
notes, eight notes.
Any kind of triplet feeling
is sort of against that.
So when there's
not accompaniment,
you have to be
really careful to--
I mean I'm not saying don't play
them, I think they're great--
but just be really careful to
articulate where your landing
them.
Because that's usually the thing
that gets rushed or dragged
and that sometimes
can send you--
GREG HOPKINS: And sometimes if
somebody's playing quarter note
triplets, maybe the other
person would play quarter notes
against that.
Just to be obstinate, or
to have that counterpoint
so I can tell that
they're really triplets.
I mean, sometimes you don't
want to use mimicry too much.
If somebody plays an idea, don't
just play the same idea back.
Play something different.
If I say hello, you
don't say hello.
Well, I guess you do.
What's your name?
Yeah, you have to
have an answer.
So let's do a flute,
guitar, and violin.
TIM RAY: We'll do
the same thing.
I'll start off with the
baseline and then I'll drop out.
But you guys keep going.
OK, here we go.
One, a two, a one,
two, three, four--
GREG HOPKINS: Not
bad, yeah it was good.
TIM RAY: OK, nice.
So-- oh no, go ahead.
GREG HOPKINS: Same as before,
nice use of the motifs.
Sometimes I'll just
play the melody.
And Tim and Eugene
will play around it,
and sometimes Tim will
quote some of the melody.
TIM RAY: Yeah, absolutely.
A couple things to
just be careful of,
I know you guys
are, to some degree,
kind of hanging
on to the rhythm.
I know, which is, of
course, what we all
do in this situation.
You're like, sometimes
you're kind of white
knuckling the beats instead of
just kind of letting it flow.
And I think sometimes
when that happens,
you start to lose a
little bit of linear flow.
I felt like there was a lot
of root improvisation based
on the roots going on.
GREG HOPKINS: It was
a little block style.
TIM RAY: Yeah, right.
And again, it's not to say
that if you did it again
you might do something
entirely different.
But it's just one thing
to be aware of, right?
And this is one of these
situations where you try it
again and you say,
OK I'm going to not
focus on the root
so much I'm going
to try to do more linear
stuff, more scales.
Maybe focus on the third or the
fifth, or just, like I said,
be a little bit more free
with what you're doing.
So, again it's nice stuff.
GREG HOPKINS: Let's
do flute and piano,
and you get another chance.
TIM RAY: All right.
Same thing.
One, two, a one,
two, three, four--
GREG HOPKINS: Bang!
OK, you stopped before the end.
We're still playing the fourth.
We're still playing
12 bar forms, right?
Did they stop before the end?
TIM RAY: Yeah , we--
GREG HOPKINS: Or maybe it was
just really good use of space.
TIM RAY: Yeah.
It's either that or you
owe us three measures.
I don't know.
We'll come back and
collect next year.
GREG HOPKINS: Let
me show you-- here's
an interesting way to practice.
This is going to be
a revolving trio.
I'm going to start
with you three, OK.
Then you're going to drop
out, you're going to join in,
and then you're
going to drop out,
then you're going to join in.
Then you're going to--
whatever three people.
And no base line.
A one, two, a one,
two, three, four--
OK.
TIM RAY: Yeah, all right.
GREG HOPKINS: To you?
Yeah.
It's a nice way to practice and
then you don't-- everyone's not
jamming in your ear, and again
you're setting parameters.
We're going to have three people
playing or two people playing.
TIM RAY: Yeah.
Yeah, you guys are
doing a great job.
I mean, I can tell--
GREG HOPKINS: You're keeping the
form and your ideas are clear.
TIM RAY: Very nice.
And again, hearing some of
the motifs come into play,
that's very cool.
GREG HOPKINS: I'm thrilled.
TIM RAY: Yeah, I--
GREG HOPKINS: [? Karagassian ?]
will be very happy.
TIM RAY: I know we're
getting close to out of time.
Are there any
questions about some
of this stuff we've been
talking about, scales, modes?
GREG HOPKINS: I need to
stress what Tim said before.
Melodies and harmonies are fine,
but the most important thing
in this music is rhythm.
Rhythm.
It's like location
in real estate.
Rhythm.
You could play any
note, it doesn't matter,
if it's in the right time and
it swings, people will buy it.
TIM RAY: That's true.
GREG HOPKINS: It's
absolutely true.
It's a rhythmic art form.
Came from dancing.
TIM RAY: Yeah, that's true.
GREG HOPKINS: I do
an analogy my class.
Let me just get to the
board right behind you
for one second.
Chalk, mighty chalk.
Harmony.
We study all this harmony.
I'm going to give
it an H that big.
But I'm a melody guy, so
melody is more important.
But rhythm is-- and
actually it should
go to the top of the building
to under the basement,
and make an R out to
Mass Ave and back.
TIM RAY: Very cool, thank you.
That's-- I would
agree with the that.
GREG HOPKINS: Rhythm is--
TIM RAY: So work on rhythm.
GREG HOPKINS: Sometimes
I just play one note.
TIM RAY: Yeah, I know.
GREG HOPKINS: Let's play
a minimalistic chorus,
just me and you.
TIM RAY: OK.
GREG HOPKINS: Two, a
one, two, three-- Yeah,
so we left a lot of
space, but when we came in
with the rhythms, they
were very strong that time.
So sometimes I think I'm
playing like a melodic drummer.
I want to lay that melody
down so people know right
where it is.
And sometimes I don't,
sometimes I'll float.
TIM RAY: Right.
And I think most of the
good players did that.
They'd float for
awhile and then they'd
lock it in with something
really specific.
That's one of things I work
on with some of my students.
Play a phrase, it
floats, and then play
something that really locks in.
So that you know the difference,
you can hear the difference,
and you can feel the
difference in your hands
as to what the different--
whatever your instrument is.
So you can feel the difference,
how it affects the music
and how it affects
your improvisation.
So, yeah that's
another great-- there's
all these exercises, etudes,
whatever you want to call them,
for improvisations
which are great to do.
GREG HOPKINS: Transcribing
is really good,
because you can't really
notate jazz rhythms.
You can write the
notes down, but you
can't notate how
they're playing them.
So you've got to listen.
And now copy Miles'
articulation,
or Clifford Brown's
articulation, or whoever,
Chet Baker.
Because they would all
play a little differently,
but-- it's all the tongue.
It's all articulation.
Because it's wind
instruments, I mean
that's where a lot of
the language comes from.
And piano.
TIM RAY: But even with
piano or guitar, still,
the articulation makes
all the difference.
You could do a whole solo
just based on two notes.
And be somewhat interesting.
I mean, it's not going
to be super interesting,
but just two notes with
articulation and strong
rhythms, you can make
an interesting solo.
Like I say, on any instrument.
I think that's true.
Drummers do it.
That's how they solo.
It's all about how
they hit the thing.
They don't have 88
keys to play with,
they've just got four
drums and a couple symbols.
GREG HOPKINS: And for
the wind instruments
it's really just a matter
of slurring and tonguing.
Some short notes,
some long notes,
some slurred notes
in the middle.
You've got to
tongue but it can't
be-- you can't
tongue too hard or it
sounds too much
like a classical.
It's got to have the funkiness
and looseness of the swing.
So yeah, working on your
articulation is very important.
That's what we do, right?
GUEST SPEAKER:
Unfortunately I think
we have to wrap because
it's the end of the period.
GREG HOPKINS: Is it
3 o'clock already?
GUEST SPEAKER: It's 3:30.
GREG HOPKINS: It's 3:30?
I'm going to get a ticket.
GUEST SPEAKER: So let's give
a round of applause for Greg.
GREG HOPKINS: Thank you.
Yeah, good play.
TIM RAY: Yeah, nice play.
GREG HOPKINS: And have no fear.
Have no fear.
Play whatever you want.
And try and hear it.